[موسيقى]
عاده ما تعج لندن بالزوار والسياح في
ديسمبر لمشاهده انوار وزينه الاعياد
المجيده وراس السنه ولكن هذا العام هناك
سبب اخر لازدحام وسط لندن بالمره والشياح
وبالاخص العرب والمسلمين منهم حيث تنير
لندن ولاول مره 30 الف ضوء في شاربك احد
الشوارع الرئيسيه في قلب العاصمه احياء
لشهر رمضان
[موسيقى]
عمده لندن صديق خان الذي اشرف على اضاءه
هذه الانوار هو من بين مليون و300 الف
مسلم يعيشون في لندن والفكره بدات من احدى
ساكينات لندن عائشه ديساي التي استوحت
الفكره من حبها الكبير لانوار اعياد
الميلاد التي واكبتها منذ صغرها علمتني
عشت في الشرق الاوسط لمده من الزمن ودائما
ما كان شهر رمضان يمثل اكثر الاوقات سحرا
بالنسبه لي واردت جلب هذا معي الى لندن هي
مدينه ترعرعت فيها ودائما ما كنت ارى
اضواء عيد الميلاد في شارع اوكسفورد وشارع
ريجنت مع عائلتي وكان افضل وقت في السنه
بالنسبه الينا وفكرت لماذا لا نرى هذا في
شهر رمضان
ردود الفعل جاء في معظمها مركبه بهذه
المبادره التي قد تضع لندن في صداره
الوجهات السياحيه في اوروبا خلال هذا
الشهر
عظام الصين
اعتقد انها جذابه جدا وتلفت انتباهنا
للتفكير برمضان وباخواننا واخواتنا الذين
يحتفلون بشهر رمضان
اعتقد ان الاضواء مهمه حقا لان هذه
المدينه مدينه كبيره وعالميه انا اؤمن
بالتنوع والشموليه
ضمن ايمانها بالتعدديه وخططها في اشراك
كافه الثقافات والديانات الموجوده في
بريطانيا تشارك
لنداء شهر اصبحت فيه الانوار والزنا جزءا
من طقوسه سواء في المنازل او في الشوارع
من لندن عروب عبد الحق العربيه